it's so nice though it's so good we had
like like a really nice onsen in the
hotel like yeah so it was one of the
best launchers
being cold all day and then just going
in the onsen and the ensembles outside
as well yeah so good so you get this
like if you kind of put yourself in the
water maybe up to like your chest or
like the bottom of your shoulders you
get this perfect blend of like your
bottom half is nice and warm and toasty
in this mineral water and then your top
is just getting comfortable
it's so anime it's it's so anime
especially like having in going in an
onsen is anime going in an onsen in snow
is just like this
it's pretty animated because
you're literally sitting there and you
you see the anime steam where the where
you know you see the steam when it like
senses everything that's literally what
it was like you couldn't see anything
like there's just so much steam yeah
yeah you couldn't see anything it was
amazing yeah so it's just like a
real-life sensor and so this view we had
of just the snow as well it looked
so [ __ ] aesthetic it was just unfair
it looked like a wallpaper it was like
unreal engine fire
it literally looked like an unreal
engine it's a rendering of not real life
yeah
it looks so good that it looks
unrealistic
that's the only part i regret not being
able to vlog because that was probably
like the most aesthetic part i can't
take a camera i can't take it what's
going on guys yeah [ __ ] dicks out
boys
[Music]
yeah cause it was it was so cold on top
that as you were like
as you were just staring at the
landscape your hair would freeze yeah so
like our hair was frozen solid while our
bottom halves were like nice nice and
toasty it was so weird because like even
though your hair is frozen and like your
shoulders and hair just like covered in
snow you're not cold because you're
sitting in boiling hot water yeah you're
sitting in boiling water so it's like
this perfect weird balance and it's just
yeah so i don't know what minerals they
had going on in that bath but like every
day i felt like silky smooth
i felt amazing it was salty baby
whatever that mineral was it was
definitely a bit i know i don't drink it
i didn't i didn't mean to drink god gets
in the answer he's like okay
i gotta coat my stomach yeah
oh you know sometimes a bit of the bath
water just slips in god i sound like
[ __ ]
i sound like [ __ ] mail-in now
you guys never licked bath water
i don't like how you use the word
slipped in yeah
that implies it's going somewhere else
yeah sometimes you're just like watching
your face or whatever and you know you
just you just get a quick touch your
face with the answer in water huh
well some sometimes like my face was
like freezing cold i needed to like warm
it up
that's what the towel was for gum
where you got the you got the you get
the water on the towel as well you know
that's true how was your skiing
snowboarding dance it was uh i think you
improved a lot i didn't think i improved
i think gone improved definitely like i
definitely my confidence went way up
from like day one to day four having
said that i think i learned the most on
day four
right because
day one two and three i had one goal
survive right and uh
the [ __ ] halo music
an started
survive no because like because you go
you go down some of these slopes and i
was having a chat with connor about you
know there are like green slopes there
are like red slopes and there are like
black slopes but at the end of the day
it's just a [ __ ] label you know god's
not god's not there creating mountains
being like i'm going to make this a
green slope at exactly these the same
angles throughout i'm just like and the
map is like yes
i will write that dude he's just like
playing like sim city with the [ __ ]
earth or whatever you know god's not
[ __ ] doing that you you're you you
get what you're given with the mountains
not every mountain and not every slope
even if it's labeled a green slope there
are different variations there are
different variables some of the red
slopes are actually easier than the
greens i would say so i would say so
yeah so if you're not familiar with uh
snow sports at all uh the slopes
normally categorized in colors or
diamonds wherever you're from shapes
yeah normally it's uh green is easiest
then some some also use blue in europe
australia
so in europe you sometimes see green you
sometimes don't it depends on which
country you're in but it's normally blue
red black and in america you have black
diamond japan also uses black diamond as
well yeah it's red circle uh sorry green
circle red square black diamond yeah
yeah oh wow yeah because in japan
there's squares black green circle green
circle because normally the the biggest
variation of difficulty comes in black
slopes yeah because they're like some of
them are literally just like they're not
treated at all yeah some of them are
just awful and so that's why there's
even uh normally a bigger scale but in
europe it's just all black yeah they're
like [ __ ] it it's all so hard yeah so
you've been skiing before yeah so on the
first day we just stayed on like
literally the baby beginner slope it was
literally
it was like the warm-up slope yeah me
joey and luke stayed on the beginner
slope the baby park slope of this
[ __ ] ski resort um and then the next
day we're like okay we're feeling
confident now
actually take the gondola up to like the
top of the mountain and ski down the
green slopes um so there was like no
distinction from me from what was a
green slope and what was a red slope we
actually followed conor and we
accidentally took a red slope i didn't i
couldn't tell the difference at all
exactly because they were they was just
like me [ __ ] fine for my life to go
down like the tiniest little slope
and that's that's like i couldn't tell
the difference between like a few
degrees not to mention the weather that
day was so [ __ ] like the visibility was
like five meters yeah yeah so the so
this uh this resort had a beginner slope
and when i said beginner slope this is
the most beginner slope i've ever seen
yeah it is literally like a flat surface
that sometimes it goes to a one percent
yeah it's like a one or two so you know
really
amazing if you're actually like
beginners beginners which luke was yeah
like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we had a friend who came
with us luke who had never skied in his
life yeah and it was a good start i mean
i think he got confident on that yeah
yeah he did he's like i've only fallen
over once i can go
if you wanted to go and do any other
slopes that were kind of difficult we
had to go all the way to the top yeah
and that's where it kind of gets you
don't really have a choice if someone's
difficult or not yeah yeah but the day
before we went up
we went up the day before and it was
like the visibility was awful yeah like
you could maybe see like five meters
ahead of you yeah and we're going pretty
fast and it's like just like i'm just
hoping i don't find someone because if i
do i'm gonna hit someone and it's like
oh god oh god it was really sketchy
really bad and then but even the second
day the visible is quite [ __ ] right yeah
yeah so the first day was a lot worse i
literally couldn't like maybe i couldn't
see what that camera oh wow maybe no no
maybe ashley where ashley is that was
about where it starts to get blurry and
i couldn't see anything right but the
next day was it was still bad yeah but
so it's bad so so we went with another
friend uh ohara he's a youtuber uh who
lives here and then we were he's chris
as well yeah and chris
as well all right so to give you to give
you a gauge of like the skill levels i
guess like where would you put yourself
what would you put yourself i would say
it's it's
you yeah chris
yeah me gone look yeah yeah so yeah so
like
uh i've like no issue doing like black
slopes or whatever so me and ohara
because we were like the most confident
ones we were like all right i was like
you go in the front you like direct them
and i'll go in the back and i'll like if
they fall over i'll help i'll help them
get back out
luckily i'm glad i was there because
luke at one point lost his ski in like
really thick snow
and when you're in ski boots you can't
really go up the mountain if you're not
used to it like if you're if you're like
a beginner it's really hard to like feel
confident running around
yeah
and i was wearing snowboard boots so i
was like all right just wait there i'll
go and dig through the snare after like
five minutes i've managed to find this
[ __ ] ski buried in the snow it gone
underneath the snow slid so you couldn't
even there was no sign yeah yeah it was
there so i had to like rummage through
yeah eventually found it so we went down
anyway but like so we took these guys up
and it was just a mess because like none
of them could like stand up chris is
good at skiing but chris is lazy right
i did notice that i didn't know chris
chris ken and eric and chris could
probably do a black slope right yeah
yeah maybe yeah if chris really tried
yeah problem is black slopes are really
tiring and take a lot of effort yeah
chris doesn't want to do that and chris
also is like he'll do reds but you
really have to convince him yeah he's
trying to do greens like chris you could
do reds so easily what are you doing
yeah because i remember like the third
or fourth day he came with me gotten
luke on a green slope because that's
when we started to get a little more
confident and he was like yeah i think
i'll stick on a green too and i'm like
[ __ ] off
get out of here you passed the exam
he's like [ __ ] skiing past us with no
problem whatsoever being like come on
boys catch up
to our boys
yeah so the second day we tried to take
them down and uh yeah how long did it
take us to get to them okay so
if i went from top to bottom without
stopping and i went as fast as i could i
could probably do it in five minutes
right yeah but that's like
probably took us
30 to 45 minutes no it took us like an
hour like it took like the two hours the
first time for the first time because
like we i swear we spent like 15 to 20
minutes looking for while you were
looking for uh luke's skis and then uh
before that as well because this was
right at the start so the visibility was
so poor
i probably would have a hard time seeing
joey from where from where he's sitting
that's how poor the visibility was um
and this was also like basically my only
like my second full day skiing so it's
snowboarding so
um i didn't know how to properly control
my board
and i remember we were trying to stick
close to a group right we're trying to
stay close to a group and i'm trying
like i'm fighting for my life just like
see where the group was right and so we
and so before every hill we all stop
before hill um unfortunately my control
of the board was not good enough that i
knew how to stop yet
so so these guys were stopped waiting
for me and luke and um so i come along
and i try to stop and i realize that i'm
stopping too late and i'm sliding down
the slope so i start shouting out oh
guys i'm going now i'm just going to go
ahead and like and and and nobody looked
nobody looked nobody looked back and i
just started stumbling down this [ __ ]
hill get halfway down and i turn around
to see if anyone's followed wait a
minute
wait two minutes wait five minutes
there's nobody and i'm just like
[ __ ] where is everybody
i am on this slope at the top of this
mountain by myself and i can't even
[ __ ] stop correctly so i had to like
i was like messaging the lion group
trying to get their attention luckily um
luckily i waited long enough for you
guys to come down because they these
guys were waiting for me this entire
yeah i thought the garm was behind us
yeah
that's how poor the visibility was um so
yeah we wasted just 20 minutes where you
were waiting for me and i was waiting
for you uh just because we couldn't
[ __ ] see each other because i was
really worried because this uh the way
that this mountain was laid out is that
like basically you have to do like
really big s's to stay on the easy ones
and if they take if they took any turn
at any point they would go down a black
slope yeah it's just a cliff and i was
like uh they're gonna die if they go
down a black slope yeah so i was like i
gotta do my best to make sure like we
got i'm like like uh what are they what
are the [ __ ] sheep dogs like
trying to round
around up all the sheep i'm like come on
boys stick together yeah
yeah it was kind of like that uh which
is why i think i learned the most on the
last day because uh on the last day we
just found like this one slope that was
perfect for beginners and had like a ski
lift take us back up and you just had
like the freedom to just do what you
want without worrying about
dying or just you know breaking also the
weather was absolutely good and the
weather was like yeah so we had three
days of god-awful weather really bad
weather and finally the last day when
we're leaving it's amazing and it's a
shame really because the next few days
after that were also really good yeah so
we kind of booked it the wrong time but
it was amazing weather really good stuff